[Music]
now come on duck is a staple of asian
cuisine and trust me a big favorite in
the ramsey household so today i'm going
to show you how easy it can be
to cook with his delicious protein and
more importantly i get this done quick
in 10 minutes this is my teriyaki glazed
duck breast right oscar pandan please
duck super lean super delicious never be
worried or scared about it is really
incredible um beautiful teriyaki sauce
bok choy a little bit of sesame seed oil
toasted uh we've got some
we've got some but we certainly lose
finish that off and these beautiful
plums okay but yes they've just become
in season and we're going to glaze them
make a beautiful sort of sweet and sour
glaze and finish that with some white
rice wine vinegar right let's have 10
minutes on the clock
now secret
to cooking a great duck
i promise you is in the pan okay
two dimensions
i want to render the fat down save that
duck fat but more importantly
let the duck rest how do we do that
first crisscross the skin
okay and all that does then is start to
break down that fat
okay don't go through the fat into the
actual meat
just go through the fat criss-cross and
what that does it creates all these
little diamonds okay and you'll see them
opening up
season it really nicely okay
salt
pepper
i've got some pink peppercorns in there
as well okay which is a really nice
fragrant way look at those things
they're so beautiful hit them into that
skin okay this is where the flavor
really starts to sort of take on a
different level okay
do this literally five or ten minutes
before you cook it never cook it ice
cold okay let it get up to room
temperature let it relax and season it
first
beautifully and then into the pan once
that pan is starting to smoke
lift up the duck
and lay the duck in and away no fat
because i want the fat from the duck
later okay
from there
in she goes all those wonderful
seasonings go throw it away get them in
there
don't waste
now start off with a high heat a little
bit seasoning on the back there i just
let those guts sit
and naturally caramelize okay
once you've got the heat
and the color in the pan turn the pan
down
okay 90 of the cookie of this duck is
going to be done skin tie down we don't
cook it on the meat side that's why it
goes dry so
turn around look
flip
seal
gas back up
okay you can see it's starting to sort
of almost caramelize the smell of those
pink peppercorns is beautiful
down here is my duck fat that's
beautiful that's the money
don't you dare waste that turn that back
over
and literally
let them sit there and cook now
once you've got the heat in the pan turn
that pan down and let them sit there for
the plums
gas on
again non-stick pan
these are useful honestly obviously plum
and duck goes brilliantly well knife
around 180 twist
and then literally
cut them in half again
in
and don't worry too much about taking
the stone out now
because the stone can come out later
once it's cooked a lot easier sometimes
you waste too much time taking the stone
out it breaks down the plum
rips it to shreds
but trust me once they're cooked the
stone just pops out so don't worry too
much
i always like to get a little teaspoon
in there
and literally just
pull out that lovely little stone there
i'll do this now
pull out
use the tip of the teaspoon
it stops you from cutting in
and wasting too much of these beautiful
plums
now once you've got that done
okay
this is where the magic starts we're
going to start making a beautiful
amazing caramel
brown sugar
into the pan
just dust the pan pan down please
oscar we're gonna make a wonderful
caramel
okay
now
just off the heat there's enough heat in
there take it off you start to see that
literally bubbling away look at that
beautiful really beautiful from there
i'm gonna pop in my star anise
that's gonna give this really nice
beautiful flavor to my plums
in goes the plums very careful
okay
it is incredibly hot so be careful
okay plums go in
and now we're starting to caramelize
beautifully back onto the heat that
sugar is breaking down and it's starting
to form a beautiful caramel we're
getting the sweetness coming out of the
plums which is giving that really nice
texture
to that beautiful plum
now for the exciting part
in goes a little bit of butter okay turn
the gas down and we start literally
making this caramel now the butter
starts to cool that down
and look
gas comes right down
don't turn those plums yet
okay from there a little bit of rice
wine vinegar
in
it bubbles away
the smell it's almost like a beautiful
sweet and sour plum
so tasty
now look at the ducks please have a look
at that
that skin
is so crispy beautiful
the speaker behind that great duck
breast
okay is leaving it
to rest whenever you rest the duck it's
so important you don't slice a duck
piping hot
slice your piping hot is going to spoil
it all the goodness goes out and you
leave the goodness on the board leave
the goodness inside the duck
now
those peppercorns it's almost like a
sort of bit of a szechuan pepper
check out
these beautiful caramelized plums now i
get my spoon
and i very carefully use the pan and
turn them over and look at that
they're caramelized
if they started to break down that rice
wine vinegar
has formed this beautiful sort of sweet
sour sauce
and then from there touch more butter
and just start building this out now
okay we don't want the plums to over
reduce
gas back up
touch more
white wine vinegar okay
now my duck is half cooked time please
jesus christ you're just going
forward on the left right
now
turn the gas right down okay
get your teriyaki glaze and just
beautifully glaze that over those duck
breasts
okay
now
just laid that round
and look what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
sear in that glaze what does that mean
it's exactly that i'm gonna roll that
round that duck fat in
and in
and that's gonna caramelize that glaze
and literally give more flavour to my
duck
now look at color that skin
look at that beautiful if you put the
glaze on there and leave it doesn't
really do much glaze it and caramelize
that blaze
now one more turn
and we're there
okay because i'm going to rest these
dark breaths for at least two minutes
so back over
on
and glaze
beautiful
really beautiful
nice
now offer the gas for now
take those breasts out
okay and literally let them sit there
don't you dare throw that away okay that
duck fat is money
take your bag choy okay
turn off the gas and just let them sit
there now
bok choy cut it in half scratch it up
and roll it through okay i'm going to
saute this in the duck fat
why
hey
it's bloody delicious and b
we don't waste that fat in goes the bok
choy
beautiful
bok choy cooked in duck fat
is a win-win now in half in half again
and slice it through bok choy
is such a delicious garnish for the duck
it's quite a substantial spinach it's
fibrous it's delicious
up with the gas
now the flavor coming on there
is gonna be incredible
okay a touch of seasoning
just a touch pepper salt
a little bit of butter in there okay
just a touch and i want half bok choy
and half noodles through there
so
flick that through
hello please
two minutes to go coriander in
sliced
i'm gonna put a little fleck just a tiny
flat of chili flake in there
coriander in
and then look a little hint just a touch
of sesame oil okay
in
and now i'm gonna start folding my
noodles through there drop them in
toss
okay
drop them in
and toss
don't just clump the noodles in there
otherwise you won't incorporate the bok
choy
turn them in and toss and you can see
over the years i've become an amazing
tosser now
in
and tossed and boy have i had practice
in and toss 60 seconds to go
thanks for coming
now
look
i've got a nice even distribution okay
oh
my
amazing
delicious noodles with the bok choy and
they're incorporated in there
that sits on the plate
generously and i mean generously
okay
beautiful really beautiful
then you take
then you take these beautiful plums
and then literally from there
you're resting that rest don't you dare
slice this thin all you do is just
literally slice that
in half and look
you sit that on top
and honestly i touch a sauce
on there
and i promise you
bob's your uncle and fanny's your auntie
and that is a beautiful delicious duck
in 10.
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down now don't
forget to pick up ramsey and 10 cookbook
inspired by this series and trust me
you're going to come out a much better
chef and if you like this video don't
forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck
you